maintenant avec tout d'abord l'assemblée
générale de la confédération des
syndicats médicaux qui s'est tenue
aujourd'hui à paris une confédération
qui représentent 75 % des praticiens
français
ces médecins sont violemment opposés en
effet à la convention qui se négocie
actuellement sans eux entre les caisses
d'assurance maladie et un syndicat de
médecins très nettement minoritaires ils
se disent prêts à fermer leurs cabinets
et à faire grève car cette nouvelle
convention pour eux équivaut à instituer
une médecine pour les riches une
médecine pour les pauvres
isabelle weschler a suivi pour nous leur
assemblée générale cet après midi à
paris nous déclarant lui l'état
d'urgence ensuite on s'est dit que si
demain une solution n'est pas trouvée
c'est l'assurance maladie qui en france
ne répondra plus à cette finalité n'ont
plus qu'à la volonté du législateur ou
de celle des gouvernements qui se sont
succédé depuis 2005
les médecins des confédérations tire le
signal d'alarmé contre le double secteur
à savoir une médecine libérale pour les
riches conventionnée pour les autres
selon eux c'est seulement par la
solidarité nationale qu'il faut résorber
le déficit de la sécurité sociale
actuellement gouvernement et qu'elles
sont omnibulé par des problèmes
économiques nous sommes d'accord pour
prendre en mains ses problèmes
économiques nous sommes d'accord pour et
avait un autre type i nous avons pris
tous les engagements et fait des
propositions honnêtes en la matière mais
nous ne voulons pas que cette
autodiscipline que cette maîtrise des
soins porte atteinte à la qualité des
soins et enfin il ya un autre problème
que j'ai souligné
c'est qu'actuellement l'assurance
maladie est avantage malades tous au
financement que des dépenses de
l'assurance maladie le parlement l'a dit
vie en france un million cinq cent mille
chômeurs qui bien sûr ne cotisent pas et
qui dieu soit loué
p déficit de l'assurance maladie il faut
donc trouver une solution de solidarité
pour ce problème
et ce n'est pas à nous médecins en
supporter seul les conséquences et
encore moins de les faire supporter
l'ensemble des malades
c'est le président de la confédération
des syndicats médicaux français qui
répondait pas isabelle béchir